well that's that's a significant
constitutional issue people don't always
agree article 3 section 2 of the
Constitution gives the Congress the
right to limit the appellate
jurisdiction of the Supreme Court it was
done most famously in a post-civil war
during a reconstruction era case in
which the Congress attempted to limit
the courts exercise of certain habeas
corpus rights directed towards some of
the southern Confederate rebels and the
Supreme Court said you and the Congress
have the right to do this and therefore
we can't continue to hear those cases so
on the one constitutional challenge that
we've actually heard to that precept the
court said Congress does have this
Authority how regularly is here and he
and i served in the Justice Department
and you remember the early 90 days when
Attorney General William Prince Smith
broached the idea of doing this with
regard to issues like abortion school
prayer and school busing there was a
great deal of controversy these
missionaries eventually getting going
with and they didn't go anywhere at
least in part because there is some
discomfort level on the part of some
senators about the proposition of
limiting the jurisdiction of courts
they're not quite sure how far they can
go and I think you used to be a lot more
education lot more discussions to what
the breadth of that right is